[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Marcus Alexander he works as a
scientist in the human nature lab at the
Yale Institute for Network science his
research focuses on genomics of social
networks the evolution of human
cooperation and large-scale field
interventions that improve and extend
human life today we'll talk with dr.
Alexander about the biome biology and
social networks in the developing world
project welcome dr. Alexander I'm
excited to be here let's start with an
overview of the project you're working
on tell us about it well for the past
two years or so the human nature lab has
been running a large public health
intervention in Honduras we're running a
network targeting trial to improve
infant and maternal health and as a part
of that this project which is led by
Professor Nicholas Christakis he has
consisted of mapping face-to-face social
networks in a large sample of about
30,000 people across 176 villages Wow
and our goal in that project is to
deliver health education so to improve
health outcomes
now the microbiome project really
started when I moved here from Stanford
where I did my postdoc mostly in
genomics I brought to this project my
interest in biology
my interest in genomics and professor
Christakis had a large social network
mapped with that bond with a lot of
information on it and opportunities to
study how health spreads through a human
network so this project which I can't
take all credit for I have to say that
it's really a brainchild of Nicholas
Christakis I started by trying to
understand what is the distribution of
bacteria that colonize human bodies
across a network of social interactions
okay let's let's talk about some terms
use social networks what do you mean by
that and also genomics can you define
that term as well for us sure so we
think social networks to be actual real
social interaction so I'm not talking
about Facebook we're talking here about
villages in a remote part of the world
people live there on at most one or two
dollars a day
they're very isolated and what we've
done is we went into the field and we
use we developed an app called trellis
which is a map for photographic mapping
of social networks so we went into this
villages and when I say we I mean
there's a team of about hundred people
working in the field and we map social
networks by first taking pictures of
everybody so there's a huge basically
Facebook so to speak of this part of the
world and then we went to people and
asked them what we call name generator'
question so I may ask you for example
who do you go to to discuss important
matters with okay and you will give me a
number of names I will I will type in
the names and we'll you will point to
the picture of the person okay so with a
number of these name generators we were
able to construct what is now the
largest map social network ever done by
any research group okay so that's what
we mean by social network what we mean
by the genomic you ask well genome is
basically the bag of genes then each of
us carries with us that give us
instructions on our body instructions on
how to function so when we say human
genome we really mean studying the
genetic code of the entire population
okay and why Honduras Welkin Duras as I
said is a very remote and a poor area of
the world one of the goals of the human
nature lab at Yale has been not only to
understand how humans interact but also
to use the knowledge that we uncover to
design better health interventions that
can actually change people's lives
so the core project in Honduras is
really trying to make the delivery of
health education to women who may be
pregnant or may become pregnant in a
very efficient way by targeting key
people in the
network and therefore helping the
intervention spread exponentially
through the entire region okay and how
long has this study been going on
so the microbiome project is a that's a
very kind of exciting new work this
whole study has been funded by the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation and by the
International Development Bank the new
study funded by the normies Foundation
consists of setting up an entire set of
procedures to collect biological
specimens from these subjects okay so
this project has started about a year
ago and what we've done we've set up a
cold chain of procedures and equipment
that is required to pick up a sample for
example a stool sample in a remote
village in Honduras freeze it in liquid
nitrogen transported to our local office
then prepare it for shipping bringing to
the Yale lab and a yellow lab we'll
share it with our collaborators Elana
Brita is a microbiologist at Cornell
she's one of our main collaborators so
what we then shared this biological
samples and analyzed the DNA that's
contained in it okay and what are you
hoping to find well we have some hints
already that microbiome in the
developing world is very different than
the microbiome in that we carry here and
why is that
for example we are exposed to different
pathogens but more importantly we have
different hygiene practices we are
exposed to new antibiotics so there's
some hints that the microbiome of this
developing area will be much more
diverse they will have many more genes
that are specialized to do different
things
adopted to the people who live there for
example diet is one of them and one
exciting part about that is that as our
societies develop and become more
industrialized a lot of biological
diversity that exists in this bacterial
population may be lost so a number of
genes a number of species may disappear
from the face of earth doing studies
like this in the developing world enable
us to get a better glimpse at the full
genetic diversity and needless to say
if we understand the bacteria that
people carry we will understand more
about the diseases that they are exposed
to and how these diseases may spread
from person to person let's talk a
little bit more about that in terms of
some of the things that were talked
about in the study terms of obesity for
instance and diabetes things that
typically you cannot catch from another
person but what you're saying is through
these things in our bodies that that is
possible
well expound on that a little bit more
yeah sure it's a quite a controversial
statement yes it is it was but it was
Nicholas's work the work of the human
nature lab maybe not 10 years ago that
first established in a network of people
in framing in the city of Framingham
that obesity clusters in a social
network that if my friend's friend gains
a few pounds I become more likely to
gain a few pounds so so far what we
think what we've thought of is this
process being a social process we affect
how each of us behaves we affect each
other's norms but what our microbiome
study asks is whether there could be
also biological mechanism behind it
right and that's fascinating exactly one
of the big discoveries that was made at
MIT Neri calms lab and Ilana Brito has
professor bitter has worked on this is
this concept of mobile genes so it turns
out that human body has about 20,000
protein coding genes bacteria have
million millions and not only that but
their genes can jump from a strain to
strain so there are these little mobile
genes that can actually move quite fast
through the bacterial population there
may be antibiotic resistance genes but
they also could be genes that increased
risk of diabetes for some people or risk
of autism or risk of obesity and other
metabolic disorders so this is really an
uncharted territory we really feel a
little bit like explorers going into a
unknown land so to speak of microbiome
and trying to map these new bacterial
strains and their genes so what would
have to happen and
order for some research to actually
indicate that one can get diabetes from
another person I think we're definitely
not there yet but the first step I would
say is to understand what species and
what genes exist in this population okay
to give you a very kind of example
connected to diabetes
carbohydrates are very important in how
we process them well it turns out that
in different parts of the world people
get their hyper carbohydrates from very
different sources right so to TIA chips
may be the main source of carbohydrates
in Honduras Arian Honduras wheat and
bread may be here well it turns out that
bacteria have evolved genes and have
populated our gut our human gut in a way
to adapt to processing those particular
carbohydrates so anything that may go
wrong in that symbiotic relationship
between the bacteria and how our body
works has the potential to affect a risk
of diabetes and other diseases right so
ultimately how long will this new study
go on for we're hoping that this will be
a multi-year study one of the things
that we also hope to do is remap all the
social networks again and see how they
change and where there are change in
social relationship is reflected in a
change in the type of bacteria or genes
that we carry in our gut okay and you
know why is it so important that this is
studied so I mentioned the idea of
biodiversity we really understand very
little about the role bacteria play in
health recent evidence you mentioned on
the diabetes but there is also recent
evidence that a number of mental health
disorders for example depression ADHD
autism anxiety may be linked to the way
our gut interacts with the microbiome so
as I said it's a very unexplored area
when we got when we take this to the
setting of the developing world there's
an added imperative to actually do
something and help people in the region
so one of the great pleasures of working
the human nature lab has been our
ability to directly affect the lives of
the people in the field so for example
the way we collect these specimens is we
have planned to have little village
clinics set up in these remote villages
where villagers can come and can get
screened for through a basic physical
and give their samples we give them back
a results of some of their studies and
we provide free deworming medication for
example for those affected so we think
that there's a symbiote there's this
partnership that we can have between
subjects that contributes to our
knowledge of basic science and on our
part as contributing to their everyday
health sure all right well this is
fascinating and I'm sure it'll be very
interesting to see what comes out of
this study so thank you very much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work thank you very much
for more information about dr. Alexander
and his research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you